former CDC director that's Tom Friedan's
his global public health initiative
resolved to save lives is releasing its
own guidance for governments to use as
they reopen now it is recommending a
four level color-coded system Tom
Frieden joins us first on CBS this
morning to lay it out for us Tom Frieden
it's good to see you again can you
explain how your plan differs from what
the CDC is recommending and why you
think it's better yeah what we're doing
is getting past two dichotomies that are
just wrong it's not open versus closed
it's not health versus the economy its
gradual stepwise data-driven science
driven reopening that takes account for
both the health and the economic impacts
of the virus and our response to it this
is a way of doing three things we
empower people to protect themselves and
their families
we hold government's accountable for
making progress and sharing the data
openly and we work together to
accelerate progress toward a new normal
so how does the color-coded system work
Tom because it sort of reminds me of a
traffic light red yellow green no matter
where you go in this country we all know
what those colors mean so what are you
saying here because it seems you know
right now it's States decide and maybe
part of the problem is there's no
uniformity we think this has to be
looked at in each community not just
state by state but parts of state cities
counties what we did Gayle was to scour
the world and find the best systems we
could find anywhere and then create
recommendations that are completely
consistent with what the White House and
CDC released but also are much more
specific and we think practical we look
at seven core indicators and that
results in four different levels with
specific recommendations for individuals
businesses schools and other
institutions can do at each of those
levels including where you need to
there's been confusion about that but
there's a big difference if you're
indoors versus outdoors if you're within
six feet or if you're not within six
feet and what the risk alert level of
your community is and a simple table
will give you that information so that
in the future Gayle we would hope that
for areas that use this checking your
Kovach risk level and deciding whether
to wear a mask this week would be as
routine as deciding whether to bring an
umbrella into the office yeah that alone
would be very could be very helpful mask
or no mask would be really really
helpful to a lot of different people you
know Tom there appears to be how shall
we say escalating tension between the
White House and the CDC you know over
the weekend Peter Navarro said that the
CDC let the country down when it came to
testing what impact do you think that
that will have or that has when you have
friction between those two when we've
looked around the world and around this
country governments that have been
guided by Public Health and that have
fully supported Public Health have
reduced infections reduced deaths and
protected their economy this isn't about
health versus economics this is about
being in it together to control the
virus as well as possible so that we can
reopen one of the things that countries
are finding all around the world is that
if people don't feel safe they don't go
out and the economy doesn't recover Yogi
Berra said if people don't want to come
to the ballpark how are you gonna stop
them if people don't feel safe going out
you're not going to be able to reopen
the environment and this risk level
approach empowers people to know what
they and what the vulnerable people and
their families and communities can do to
stay safe and help other people be safe
all right Tom Frieden we thank you for
joining us it's always helpful to have
you here thank you sir